u.s president joe biden has joined
around
30 other nations in formally recognizing
the massacre of
hundreds of thousands of armenians over
a century ago
as a genocide in a statement biden said
he
sees armenians pain and affirms their
history
many historians regard the mass killings
which began in 1915
as the first genocide of the 20th
century
but turkey rejects the term
marching forward to look back armenian
officials led the nation
in commemorating the horrors of the past
the procession
at this hilltop memorial in the capital
yerevan
included prime minister nicole
passionian
members of the public too streamed in to
honor the dead
i
i love armenia and genocide should be
recognized
in 1915 a million armenians were
brutally murdered by ottoman turks
many more were deported and sent on
death marches
into the syrian desert
armenians have long campaigned for the
crimes against their people
to be recognized internationally as
genocide
turkey argues that there was no
systematic attempt to wipe out armenians
and no such order from the ottoman
authorities
but nearly 30 countries have recognized
the atrocities
as genocide
[Applause]
germany's parliament voted to adopt the
term in 2016.
that resolution sparked an angry
reaction in turkey
president erdogan saying germany should
be the last nation on earth
to accuse others of genocide
many armenians would consider the
diplomatic spats over terminology
a distraction from the memory of
atrocities of more than a century ago
that haunt their nation to this day
well for more let's bring in dw sumisto
muskanda who joins us now from
washington d.c
hello to you sumi so u.s president joe
biden
released a statement just a short time
ago recognizing the mass killings of
armenians as
genocide how significant is this
statement this is pretty significant
mariana you know for the last few
decades
u.s presidents really have avoided using
the word
genocide out of fear of angering turkey
turkey seen here as
an important partner a nato ally of
course and the last president to use the
word genocide was actually ronald reagal
reagan in 1981 and since then many a
president has promised on the campaign
trail
to call what happened to armenians in
world war one genocide but once they've
gone into the white house
they have not followed through and what
has happened in recent years is in 2019
congress actually passed a resolution
deeming this as
genocide and last year president biden
on the campaign trail said he would do
the same
and now he has done so he has followed
through in the white house so clearly
uh president biden here breaking with
his predecessors and mariana that is
pretty significant
now sumi why do you think it was
important for
president biden as you say to break with
his predecessors
and change washington's position on this
classification
now
well if you ask biden administration
officials they will say
that they want to make human rights a
central piece of their foreign policy
platform but
they haven't confronted other countries
on human rights like saudi arabia for
example so why
turkey and why now on this issue well
you have to understand that there is
growing frustration in washington
with the turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan the u.s really was not happy
about turkey's decision to purchase
russian missile systems
that actually triggered sanctions
against turkey they also were not happy
about
turkey's role in libya and also in syria
and there's a general sense marianna the
turkey has been backsliding
on questions of human rights and
democracy so it seems that these
disagreements really bolstered president
biden's resolve
to take action well we have already
heard a reaction
from the turkish government it says it
entirely
rejects the u.s decision to classify
this
armenian massacre as a genocide sumit
what do you think the impact is going to
be
on ties between the u.s and turkey
moving forward
well i just mentioned some of the
disagreements you know clearly the ties
are not at the best point they have been
but the buy administration knew
that this would warrant or this would
see a heavy reaction a harsh
reaction rather from ankara and that's
why in that statement that was released
today
president biden wrote we do this not to
cast blame but to ensure that what
happened
is never repeated and actually president
biden even called president erdogan
yesterday and in the official white
house readout of that call it makes no
mention of the two leaders having
discussed this announcement today but
many reports here say that they did
discuss this so
clearly president biden was trying to
warn president erdogan about this but
as i said marianna the relations between
the two countries at this point
are not at their highest point that
they've been
sumisomoscanda reporting for us from
washington thank you so much
you